bis dahin berichten wir hier bei bild
live auch mal wieder über brennende
autos in berlin
jede nacht andere nachrichtensender
berichten dass schon gar nicht mehr weil
es anscheinend so normal geworden ist
wir finden nicht dass das normal ist und
berlin steht gerade sie sehen diese
bilder die sich hier jede nacht aufs
neue abspielen in der hauptstadt
brennende autos wir stehen gerade von
einer neuen eskalation linker gewalt am
freitag bei uns im studio ralf schuler
unser chef des parlamentsbüros hierbei
bild neue eskalation der gewalt am
freitag wieso da wird eine wagenburg
geräumt die im bezirk
friedrichshain-kreuzberg aufgebaut ist
das ist die rigaer straße werden
vielleicht einige schon mal von gehört
haben immer wieder eskalation der gewalt
ein besetztes haus und es ist dort ein
öffentlicher platz der von autonomen wie
sie sich selbst bezeichnen gehalten wird
und der soll geräumt werden am freitag
ist die räumung angesetzt und im vorfeld
waren das sozusagen drohgebärden der
linken szene um jetzt schon mal zu
zeigen den finger weg von unserem
domizil man muss sich einfach mal klar
machen jeder kaffee hocker der irgendwo
in berlin auf den bürgersteig gestellt
wird muss genehmigt sein muss eine muss
eine gebühr entrichten für für solche
sachen und hier wird öffentlicher raum
einfach so besetzt und gehalten als
autonomes zentrum so etwas geht einfach
nicht und es gibt auch gewalt davon
ausgehen drogendelikte davon aus und man
muss es einfach mal so klar sagen wenn
hier drohgebärden in form von zerstörten
autos
vorher praktiziert werden das ist eine
art
grenzlinie zum zum bürgerkrieg wo
einzelne leute für sich recht in
anspruch nehmen und sozusagen selbst
vollstrecker sind das ist die rigaer
straße hier die auch nach fast jede
nacht wieder brennt da wird müll auf die
straße geräumt dann anschließend
angezündet die einsatzkräfte müssen
immer wieder raus um die arena ist hier
auch keiner gesagt wir sehen gerade jede
nacht die einsatzkräfte der feuerwehr
müssen von der polizei massiv gestützt
werden mit schilden vor steinwürfen vor
angriffen mit molotow cocktails es ist
wirklich brutal es ist linksterrorismus
man muss es vielleicht einfach mal so
sagen
und dass das auf die dauer nicht weiter
geduldet werden kann ist eigentlich
offensichtlich wäre in jeder anderen
stadt offensichtlich aber berlin du hast
es gesagt es wird manchmal schon gar
nicht mehr erwähnt berlin ist an vielen
stellen einfach aus empört möchte ich
mal sagen ein 1 14 jahre bauzeit für
einen flughafen kann man irgendwann dann
auch nicht mehr hören die linksextreme
gewalt ist lange zeit geduldet worden
unter dem letzten senat gab es mehrere
versuche besetzte häuser zu räumen ist
immer wieder vereitelt worden von
bezirksbürgermeister von
widerstreitenden parteien in der
senatskoalition und die rigaer straße
ist auch eine endlose geschichte von
infrastruktur von netzabdeckung von
drogenkriminalität ganz zu schweigen bis
hin zu bizarren geschichten dass
ausgerechnet der chef des renault clans
anbietet den görlitzer park ein
stadtbekannter drogenumschlagplatz
sozusagen als ordnungsmacht zu zu
beschützen das ist eigentlich völlig
bizarr und die kanaren die in berlin als
das bessere ordnung jahr gelten absolut
absolut und vor diesem hintergrund ist
es eine weitere fortschreibung einen
wirklich eines unhaltbaren zustandes in
berlin welche rolle spielt der rot rot
grüne senat dabei wie lange hat man da
und vor allem auch warum sehenden auges
offenbar weggeschaut naja man muss
einfach sich klar machen dass für teile
der berliner grünen die noch ein
bisschen anders sind als die
bundesgrünen die hier früher als
alternative liste angetreten sind dass
teile der grünen aber eben auch der
linkspartei und der des linken spd
flügels sich eben auch als ein stück
weit politischer arm der autonomen szene
sehen und dass da auch personelle
überschneidungen gibt viele sind aus
einem frontstadt
linken revoluzzertum raus gewachsen und
heute in der berliner landespolitik
deshalb hat man immer so ein bisschen
berührungsängste gehabt und hat das auch
ein bisschen verklärt jedes jahr zum
ersten mal wieder die revolutionäre
erste mai demonstration teil kreuzbergs
werden hat sozusagen zum sperrgebiet
auch der riesige verlag von uns muss
dann immer massiv geschützt werden das
ist eigentlich alles unhaltbar andere
länder gehen hart gegen vor
innenminister rhein in nordrhein
westfalen ganz klar hart durchgreifen in
berlin ist das bis jetzt unterblieben
[Musik]